you love Alex Jones on this show you
can't get Alex Jones anywhere else the
government has banned him he's based and
so the only place to hear his conspiracy
theories and whacked-out stuff is right
here on ya so because you love when he
comes on our show I've arranged today
for you to talk and to enjoy Alex Jones
let's go right to Alex and you can see
them up on the screen controlled
corporate media gatekeepers generate
Satanist Howard Stern and the leader of
[ __ ] pedophile cults Jimmy Kimmel by
the way you're having a tremendous I was
just telling Jimmy you're having a boy
what's the matter it seemed like you
shot out of a cannon boom bra if you eat
the bone broth it is so good it's loaded
with vitamin r listen Jimmy I know
you're in New York right now for the
annual Bilderberg meeting where the
technocracy take strokes and the temple
and interfaces with the palate ears for
planetary control the interdimensional
connection right I know that right no
he's in the town for something called
the upfront for ABC advertising event
that's not true it's the Bilderberg
meeting listen I cover this all in my
new book Alex Jones exposes globalist
pedophile cults again so everyone is
excited that you're here this morning
what is going on they've taken you off
every media outlet you we can barely see
you anywhere we have been shadow band up
by the way I should mention I brought
the panel in studio today I brought the
guys in we got George Soros Hillary
Clinton Arab Obama the triad of evil
that's your team they're all there with
you that is my team ah
George Soros you know Jimmy Kimmel right
you got a plan I haven't seen you since
the Luciferian sacrifice
Wow Friends Reunited it's beautiful OS
is on your panel that you're talking to
there about Jimmy get up the great
Hillary Clinton over here the reptilian
Antichrist
I love eating Mexican immigrants arms
and fingers thank you very much Hillary
Howard I know you used to have a George
Soros come on your show all the time
when you guys would play we love Soros
back in the day yeah I love that back in
2002 t remember that no I'll prove it to
you right now roll the clip you'll see
[Music]
80% of that was lost to the radio
audience it was pretty great and have a
talk with Alex later I know you're
constantly calling for the transmission
game the demonic experiments being done
on lower hominids you go on your show
you admit your subhumanoid I know you do
this Jimmy don't lie to me well you stop
attacking Jimmy Jimmy is my guest oh I
have a clip of Jimmy admitting human
clone clip all right
we also have ourselves have I been
entirely true well I don't know about
you but I'm not I haven't been entirely
truthful I'll give you one example these
are my subhuman crab claws a horse
humanoid hybrid believe you now I know
you this we try to give you an
opportunity to get your voice out there
and I hope you enjoy I understand you
got to go give the try comms merv
technology for the ICBMs by the way
apologize to the panel we didn't get to
clean out the computer Arab Obama do you
have anything you'd like to add tonight
[Laughter]
stop shop for survival gear boats and
wellness supplements at a discount price
but in fo wars.com you get info for your
Patriot Act's by the Patriot pack you
get the new books you get the secret
ancient brain bill pull the vitamins ho
toxins by now and you'll get at Jimmy
Kimmel loves NAMBLA t-shirt don't you
love him I love it
by the way the the visuals I hope people
she is that going to be on the app but
we're gonna put that on
[Laughter]